happy holidays everyone a quick note
before we get started we're excited to
announce that our film minimalism a
documentary about the important things
hits Netflix this Thursday December 15th
2016 just in time for the holidays so
gather your friends family and
co-workers and enjoy the film with each
other this holiday season all right now
on to a special holiday episode of the
minimalists podcast enjoy
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
happy holidays happy holiday happy
holiday we really need to do just a a an
entire episode and nothing but song
where we answer people's questions
clearly as they could tell our voices
are really good or we could record our
own Christmas album let's do it hello
everybody welcome to the middlemost
podcast this is where we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to episode
number 41 today we're going to talk
about the holiday is Ryan last night I
almost died literally oh my god you so
remember almost three years ago now you
wrote an essay about this I think it was
called the days after the crash or life
after the crash oh yeah after the crash
yeah so so there's an essay on our
website called life after the crash
about a week before Ryan and I went on
this crazy hundred city tour you were
you were you you were up in Canada yeah
we we started in Banff drove over to
Vancouver this was all during the winter
it's like when we got to Vancouver until
January yeah we told the worst time to
drive it from from Banff yeah we told
people you drove a van and the even the
Canadians were looking at it's like you
guys are nuts but we made it totally
safe did you have snow tires roll
instead well it was it was Mariah's cars
it doesn't really matter but she didn't
have snow tires Chevy Malibu is the
equivalent American equivalent of a
Toyota Corolla pretty much but but yeah
we were actually coming back we were in
Washington about two hours west of
Spokane and it was not that bad it just
a little slushy out like nothing
compared to what we were driving in in
Canada and yeah I was just a little
slushy some kid and his girlfriend were
driving lost control like basically got
right in front of us and we ended up
t-bone
because we had no choice they just like
literally just came from one lane and
then we're sideways right in front of it
right they they recited not you yeah
yeah and then they drugged us into the
ditch
and yeah the car flipped it was nuts man
thank God we were in our seatbelts yeah
you got you flipped over I mean could
have died yeah and to put a lot of stuff
in perspective for me I'm only that
happen man I was so shocked I was
actually in Spokane at the time I
remember getting some call from you and
you're like you know we might need a
ride I don't know what's happening and
and it was it was so freaky because I
like the adrenaline from something like
that it's nuts man it's unbelievable so
I experienced something similar last
night wow what happened when you were
out Christmas tree hunting yes we went
we drove down the Lolo Lolo National
Forest and so you start going down these
roads that the road the term road is
used very loosely here now I have a
four-wheel-drive vehicle and and so we
we drove up just fine with me and VEX
and Ella and you park and you you give
this five dollar Christmas tree permit
license whether it's a permit yet to put
on the tree when you put it on your roof
or whatever so it don't think you stole
it and so we went we finally like found
the tree it took us a couple hours to
find a good one for the living room and
we're driving back down the the mountain
or the hill or whatever it down this you
know it's a decline and as we're driving
it just turns into ice and it's more ice
and I don't have chains in my car
somewhere and I'm like I didn't expect I
mean this it's not even that snowy out
and so we got up just fine but on the
way down I started sliding and there's
obviously no guardrails or anything like
that and I started sliding into a creek
that was maybe a six foot drop off oh my
god enough to certainly flip the car I
mean six foot drop off we're I don't
know a couple feet from completely
flipping the car and so Beck's got out
of the car and we started putting like
sticks and twigs and stuff in the road
because we were far away from being
anywheres no cell service at all where
we were
and so not only did we almost flip into
the creek but we wouldn't have been able
to call anyone either and it's dusk
because it's like 4:30 and and so it's
getting close to dark and it's freezing
outside and Ella
you know she's three years old so she
can't stop like talking and what's that
sound and and and you know just doing
everything a three-year-old would do in
driving me crazy because my Adrenaline's
through the roof and it's not her fault
it's just me like trying to deal with
this situation and we pulled the floor
mats out of the car and use those on top
of the ice and we finally found someone
who was any doubt down toward the bottom
of the hill or the mountain or whatever
we found someone who had some chains and
use those to get get away from this ice
that was literally drifting the car
Billy into yeah so we have this
Christmas tree on top of the car and and
we're getting ready to just drift into
this Creek and it was terrifying but
talk about punctuating and otherwise
nice experience like it it was it was a
great experience for us to go out and do
this Christmas tree hunting although
lesson learned make sure I have chains
with me if I'm going to go do that again
we did it last year but we did a
completely different area where there
that wasn't necessary at all yeah so
next time you know maybe do it somewhere
different as well you're like living in
the Pacific Northwest and like you just
I have had a lot of strange lessons like
that of terrain and making sure I have
the proper attire and yeah that's crazy
man you know I'm glad you're safe I'm
glad that you and Becks and Ella
sandwich is safe yeah well thank you i
yeah so my and man I tell you it was it
was terrifying I if you see my car right
now like the interiors a total mess
there's like pine needles and stuff
everywhere and you know me and in my OCD
way is like everything drives me crazy
but we had to use the floor mats to
drive a LAN and so man it was quite the
experience the holiday experience so
easily it's a holiday I won't forget
that's for sure Wow my adrenalin still
feels up quite a bit
so today with sock holidays we have a
voicemail suite we have a few of them
here our first question is from Emily in
Austin Texas I am having a hard time
getting into the quote holiday spirit
this year normally I feel loved and
thankful and upbeat during the holidays
but this year we won't be traveling to
see her family there's been some health
issues this year a recent death in the
family how do you two get into the
holiday spirit especially while avoiding
conspicuous consumption well I'll tell
you what Emily I'll tell you - Josh tell
me pumpkin pie always puts me in the
mood man the holiday mood oh the holiday
spirit so that's a good way or maybe
some sort of kink you had it may that's
cool maybe some hot cocoa with the
cinnamon stick in it that's always a
good treat on the holiday season but no
I think it's a really good question I
remember I think the one of the one of
the one of my favorite experiences as a
kid like growing up when I started to be
able to kind of do holiday stuff like
when my mom and dad split up my mom kind
of started celebrating Christmas she
took me to in in Cincinnati they have
this thing called holiday and lights and
it's like just like these really awesome
Christmas lights where you know they
just do different things yeah this is
ooh it's really really beautiful but uh
but not only that we would drive around
to look at other people's decorations
uh-huh and like I always love doing that
man like just going around and kind of
seeing how other people would decorate
their homes that put a lot of time and
effort into it and just some like
beautiful beautiful decorations you know
mom didn't have to do that at home we
didn't have to put up a ton of
decorations ourselves to do that we
could totally enjoy other people's
decorations but you know of course the
old saying is true - Emily it is better
to give than receive so find ways you
can give this this Christmas or this
holiday season find people who you can
help get into the holiday mood because I
I promise you that if you go out of your
way to give your time to your community
and help them get into the mood it will
by default help you get into the mood -
so there's a few
recommendations I thought of you know I
totally agree with the the giving piece
and it reminds me this morning I log on
to give well org and they have their top
charities we've talked about them before
and I gave in other people's names for
the holidays this time around and so
instead of just you know donating on
behalf of myself or whatever donated as
a gift for for someone else and so that
allows them to also see the progress of
what's going on
with their gift that you you gave them
so if you are buying malaria mosquito
nets to help prevent malaria somewhere
then then the person that you're
donating on behalf of gets an update and
they're able to then they see the
progress as opposed to that that necktie
you got them or or whatever else so
totally agree with that the other thing
the only other thing that I would would
mention is that if you're having trouble
getting into the holiday spirit figure
out what your triggers have been in the
past so like Ryan said often it's good
just Christmas lights or or some pumpkin
pies or some pumpkin pie Christmas trees
cinnamon sticks whatever look well also
- I love love love cheesy Christmas
music like even the drives people crazy
yeah in the stores and maybe it did when
we were in the corporate world but like
when I say cheesy I'm talking like
William Shatner Christmas oh my girl is
like the cheesier it is the better it is
for me do you remember when we we used
to manage some retail stores and the one
in Westchester Ohio the old one there on
Cox Road we I don't think you were
working at that store at the time I
think you were at the the Mason store
but we had the music the Christmas CDs
well the player got stuck and and so we
it wasn't the one that like streamed the
music you had to like replace the CDs
and they give you new one each month and
so the the CD player got stuck and so we
were stuck with Christmas music after
the holidays and we didn't fix it for
months so it was something like February
or March there was still Christmas music
playing and unbelievable we just so
people were being very proactive get
into the spirit earlier that year
no I think that's great so some
Christmas music is certainly a trigger
figure out what your triggers are for
some people it might be a pumpkin spice
latte I don't recommend that personally
because it's just a milkshake that's
warmed up but it could be Christmas
lights it could be a Christmas tree
it could be decorations it's really up
to you to determine what your triggers
are they get you into the holiday spirit
find those and also last thing is when
you're shopping if you are doing some
some Christmas shopping this year try to
go out of your way to support some local
businesses if you have the opportunity
to do so it keeps the the money in your
community and it goes a lot farther in
the community when you're supporting
your local businesses Emily there's an
entire gift-giving chapter in our book
called essential it's an essay
collection that Ryan and I wrote over
the last five years we published it last
year the audiobook version just came out
last month and so I'd love to send you
an audio book version of that or if
you'd prefer an e-book or print version
we'll send that to you as well the
entire gift-giving chapter plus there
are 11 other other chapters on
minimalism and mindfulness and stuff and
decluttering and etc so I hope you find
some value happy holidays Emily our next
question is a unique question from
Theresa over in Seattle I heard
Joshua mention that he doesn't drink and
I'm just curious if that's been an
outcome of minimalism and choosing a
different life or if that predated this
experience I live in Seattle and people
drink a lot here so I'm looking at it
for myself and also maybe this will fit
nicely into any holiday segment you do
you know we weren't going to include
this in this episode except toward the
end Teresa said this might fit well into
a holiday segment and I agree that often
during the holidays drinking is amped up
and in fact often encouraged whether
it's the increased number of commercials
especially within football seasons on
and you see nothing but beer commercials
and on on
while you're watching football games or
if you're like going through the story
they got the seasonal beers like these
are seasonal wine here's our season
here's Sam Adams seasonal pumpkin which
is horrible beer in my opinion but yeah
exactly so is my not drinking a result
of minimalism or did it predate my brand
of minimalism sorry yes and no I mean
and I've I've never had a drink in my
life and I likely won't ever have a
drink in my life but that really has to
do with my childhood I grew up in a
household where my mother was an
alcoholic and she started drinking when
she was 40 years old so I was four at
the time and our life changed
considerably for the worse after that we
were poor we were on government
assistance and I associated a lot of
discontent with alcohol alcoholism in
particular and so that is deeply
embedded in me but also I know I have a
very addictive personality and so if I'm
going to get addicted to something I'd
rather be writing or creating or or
doing something that is valuable to me
and creates value for other people as
opposed to pacifying myself drinking
because I also know that I am more
predisposed to be addicted to something
like that I mean if I if I started
drinking now you just might never hear
another podcast because I was just keep
drinking until I can't function yeah it
would not be a functioning alcoholic
I wouldn't be able to function and so I
decide not to drink but I also like to
have control over my my own faculties I
suppose I like to have control over my
my mind and my body and I don't need the
the social lubricant in order to to be
competent in a social situation in fact
situations that require a social
lubricant to seem to me a bit
inauthentic because we're trying to
bring out our authentic selves that
under the guise of having this this veil
this veneer of acceptability like I'm
drinking and so now I'm allowed to say
this stuff I want to be able to say the
things that I say I want my my
everyday self to be congruent right I
want to be congruent my online self to
be congruent with my with my private
self to be congruent with my public self
to be congruent with my sober self and
if I were to drink I'd want that person
to be congruent with with Who I am now
and so I think I think that's important
to to to realize that if I am if I ever
worth a drink which I don't anticipate
but if I ever were to drink IIIi would
want to make sure that there was a
reason that I'm doing yeah yeah I mean
for me god man it's funny cuz like I
remember like going to your house and
like either like it was always a
crapshoot like when we were kids yeah
like we walk home from school like go to
your you know go to your house after
getting cheeseburgers and having those
as snacks and then and then go in your
house to play toejam and Earl Sega
Genesis oh my god is that your
recommendation for later today but I
remember like we would go to your house
and I just remember thinking like either
like Josh's mom is going to be home and
you might just be making dinner right
she might be like passed out on the
couch or she may not be there at all so
I remember yeah like your experience
with with alcohol and your mom it was it
was a big turn-off for you where I was
the exact opposite right I was like for
me alcohol was not a social lubricant as
much as that's when I you know people my
mom would have people over and when they
would drink that's when it seemed like
oh they're having a good time the
grown-ups are having fun yeah exactly so
I've always associated it with having a
good time and that is why I have always
you know kind of used alcohol as a
pacifier or or yeah racking up $300 bar
tabs I mean that's something that you
know from a very young age I looked at
it you're saying when you had a prot
like in your 20s you there was a problem
racking up a $300 bra tab is yeah like
what problem right right like like why
having that experience with alcohol is
why yes why when I was 21 22 when I
could buy alcohol like that is
what I did a lot right and I have like
significantly decreased my alcohol
intake but I will say like I was just up
at Flathead Lake last weekend we had
like you know friendsgiving
and what does friendsgiving
friendsgiving well basically you just
get together I wouldn't know how many
friends so you get together with a bunch
of friends and you have one of these
friends you have Thanksgiving after you
know after Thanksgiving okay sometimes
it's not Xing me like a lot of a lot
I've heard the term I'm just unfamiliar
with so friends giving a second
Thanksgiving no it's okay so there's a
couple reasons to have friends giving
the first reason that I can think of is
for example I got friends here who don't
have any family in Montana right they
didn't fly home for Thanksgiving so they
were literally in Montana on
Thanksgiving with no family around to
really hang out with there are so those
friends got together and they decided to
celebrate Thanksgiving together as
friends right so they call it friends
giving the other thing is okay so you
you live somewhere you have family that
you spend Thanksgiving with but you also
want to spend time with your friends so
then you have like yeah a second
Thanksgiving with just friends it's
typically like that in that scenario it
typically wouldn't be held on
Thanksgiving like the one we had like I
said we had it on Friday so it was it
was the day after Thanksgiving that's
much better than like waking up at 3:00
a.m. to go shop you didn't like that
wasn't your friends giving right but
that's a good idea for non Halloween
other holidays not for not Thanksgiving
friends miss Valentine's Day for friends
I don't know if it's going to translate
as much but yeah I think I think it's a
great idea especially because you know
people move and they end up in different
places and yeah like you said they often
don't have family around and so it's a
great way to connect with other people
on that holiday and be grateful for sure
yeah so we were we had friends giving
over the weekend and it was there's a
lot of drinking going on and it's like I
I will you know I would love to sit here
and say like oh I never
you drunk but you know what dude it's
like we're hanging out we're having
drinks and then the next thing you know
it's like oh man I'm a little tipsy
right now you know what I don't have any
responsibilities to do tomorrow I'm just
gonna go and have another drink so for
me like that's that that is how alcohol
works for me it's like this it I don't I
don't use it to run or it's a hide it's
more of like when I get that relaxed
feeling that I'm like oh man if I had a
beer right now I'd even be more relaxed
mm-hmm and so that's what I have to look
out for personally so so when you when
you have that trigger that if I had this
then I'd be even more like then you
realize okay maybe there's there's a
problem yeah yeah and there's not and I
don't you know see alcohol is a problem
in my life right now
with the exception of it's just not
healthy really I mean I mean you know
empty calories yeah there are articles
out there like you know a couple glasses
of wine may be healthy and that might be
true but you know if I have a couple
glasses of wine every single day I'm
gonna want to have more than probably
just a couple glasses of wine so for me
to like drink everyday is not it's just
not conducive to the way I want to live
my life it's definitely not conducive
for my health so so there is this like
this line that I feel like I ride when
it comes with with alcohol that's why I
brought up that I was a couple podcasts
ago that book how to quit the drink easy
mm-hmm he's because Mariah and I have
been talking about for health reasons
she has a horrible like gut issues you
know microbiome stuff that that isn't in
alignment I in her gut and alcohol if
she drinks more than like just a couple
drinks it really hurts her and for me
like if I like over the weekend I don't
know how many drinks I had but like
Monday morning I woke up and I had like
you know like the rosy red cheek I my
scalp was really dry so there are these
adverse effects that um that yeah we
have definitely been you know kind of
flirting with cutting it out but I guess
you know when it comes to alcohol in
general I would just say like no alcohol
is not the devil right but if it is
something that you have in your life
that is a pacifier and it is having
an adverse effect meaning that it is it
is a net negative in your life then it
certainly is something that you know
some you know people should stay away
from so during the holiday season
yeah if first off don't feel pressured
to drink but if you're someone who has
you know an issue with alcohol then like
if it was me I would avoid the situation
like if I was really really struggling
with alcohol
I wouldn't went to the lake last weekend
sure yeah I mean or someone like me
where it's easy for me to just say no I
don't drink and and that's that's the
end of the story and even if you are it
even if you drink sometimes you you can
say no I don't drink and because you're
not drinking right now and that's not a
lie if you're if you're not actually
drinking right now so if it is posing
some sort of problem or if it's just it
sounds like Theresa it's raising a red
flag for you and this is where I said no
it's not about minimalism for me but
some what is what Ryan on the last
episode talked about what is minimalism
really it's the intentional use of your
resources right you're using your
resources more intentionally and so one
of those resources might be your health
or your time or your attention and and
if you are being very deliberate with
with those things might mean that you
don't want to drink right now because it
is occupying a space in your brain that
you don't feel you don't feel that it
should be occupying and it has raised
the red flag for you and if that's the
case then yeah you can give it up I mean
I do these experiments all the time with
other things that I give up whether it's
internet at home or a cell phone or
television etc etc etc a lot of them
revolve around technology sometimes it's
around having a car or whatever it may
be and you can do that with anything in
your life to see whether or not it's
adding value it's not depriving yourself
of something that's vital what you're
doing is removing it so that if you do
bring it back in you can do so more
deliberately Theresa in our book
everything that remains the whole first
chapter kind of talks about our
childhood growing up and and and in that
situation I was gonna read a little bit
but there it's it's a long snippet so I
won't do that here but Theresa I'd love
to send you either an e-book
version of that or the print version of
our memoir everything that remains it
was really about the the first or the
last five years of our lives go in from
the suit-and-tie corporate guys to
becoming the minimalist but to set that
up we had to sort of talk about our
troubled past and go to a lot of detail
of our childhoods and teenage years etc
so I hope you find some value in that
book Teresa dude I was just thinking
what's that when I was so when I got
divorced there like 22 uh-huh I moved in
with one of my friends we were roommates
and we drank every single day and I was
just thinking about the amount of
alcohol we consumed it was a case it was
at least a case of beer each every
single day like that it was unbelievable
man oh my goodness yeah it's it's yeah
well my doctor I said you know he said
to me that if you have and I don't know
what the actual stats are on this or
people may disagree but my medical
doctor said that if you're drinking four
times a week two or more drinks that's
what they consider to be an alcoholic oh
okay
so four times a week two or more drinks
a day now how do you define drink is it
the big gulp from 7-eleven I think it's
eight ounces of alcohol whether but with
wine I would assume would be less than
right or like liquor around there way
like yeah yes I don't know whatever the
serving size is would be one drink so if
you're doing four times a week two or
more drinks
that is the line they determine for
alcoholism and and so maybe maybe think
about that as well we have another
question here this one is from Sarah in
Canada with regard to the holidays my
family's carried on with some traditions
that I don't feel add much value to my
life anymore like buying lottery tickets
of stocking stuffers and making 10
different kinds of cookies to eat when
one or two would be plenty and I was
wondering if you had any suggestions on
how to broach a conversation with them
about changing those deeply rooted
family traditions that have been going
on for almost thirty years Sarah you
know yeah this is a tough one right like
you you go to
someone's place they give you a bunch of
gifts or you know they here take all
these leftovers and it feels really
really bad to say no you know her
question was how to kind of start that
conversation I know that I've started
the conversation a lot and the and the
best way to do that first off is to show
someone and tell someone how much you
appreciate them whether it's a friend or
family member you know explain how much
you do appreciate their sentiment you do
appreciate their attention you love them
very much but you know when they have
certain actions for example
at the holidays when they are making a
bunch of cookies and giving a bunch of
stocking stuffers that that you feel
overwhelmed when you're around things
like that and explain to your family
member how it would really really help
you and joy the holiday more if you
didn't have to participate in every and
every single event and and if you and if
you didn't get as many gifts or if you
weren't forced to take home as many as
much food or leftovers or whatever and
in that that uh that helps a lot just
kind of having that conversation and I
know I talked about this on the podcast
or two ago as well whenever you are
having conversations like this don't
ever use the word you in a negative way
any time you use the word you it's I
love you I appreciate you and then when
you want to talk about something
negative like the holidays are
overwhelming then put it on yourself I
feel overwhelmed during the holidays and
I really need some support and usually
family will react what of that and you
know as I was like kind of thinking
about this response to her voicemail I
thought well so I go to a family member
and I say hey I feel really overwhelmed
it would really help me enjoy the
holidays more if I didn't participate in
this stuff well the family member could
come back and say well it would really
make my holiday better if you did
participate right so it's like what are
you do in that situation well I think in
that situation you can find a common
ground meaning that you both want to
enjoy the holidays so how can you come
to maybe a compromise to do the holiday
so in our compromise for the holidays so
with Sara's example you know maybe it's
okay can you please just pick one either
you know give me a million different
cookies or you know go ahead and give me
lottery tickets in the stockings but
please don't give me everything right
yeah and I think it's important to to
note here that some traditions are
fairly innocuous baking cookies is an
innocuous tradition the where it becomes
problematic is us eating a bunch of
cookies right I mean you you it may be
very difficult for you to get me to eat
even a cookie at this point because I'm
so focused on on my health
it just wouldn't align with my values
and and so no I won't step outside of my
values to eat a cookie to appease
someone and their tradition I will thank
them if they give us cookies and and and
say thank you and be grateful for the
the gesture because they're attempting
to in some way add value to my life but
I also think it's important to notice
that or to note that traditions are by
definition not flexible because they are
a tradition and they can be a very
long-term tradition but also keep in
mind that you can you can start new
traditions and and so if you're really
struggling with the existing traditions
then the best way is to not say get rid
of these traditions or what are the new
traditions that you can bring into your
life and so I talked about Christmas
tree hunting like that's a new tradition
that I've started I never did that it
took 34 years of my life before I ever
went Christmas tree hunting which first
time I went was last year and and you
know since then of course I'll I will
continue to do that hopefully in a more
safe way next year but there are other
traditions that you can start as well
what is it hiking or building snowmen or
snowball fight so that's the other thing
we did yesterday when we were up on the
mountain is Ella loves like throwing
snowballs at us she also loves to like
make a snowball she doesn't want us to
make a she'll make the snowball hand it
to us and ask me to throw the snowball
at her after she's made it and so I have
a lot of videos helping Ella with with
the snowball yes
occasion I just took a rock in the
middle of it oh my god he's jokingly
so but no you can yeah so maybe it's
snowball fights maybe it's ice skating
you won't get me ice skating although
I went has 28 or 29 and went ice-skating
for the first time as an adult I've gone
a couple times a kid and almost killed
myself several times so you won't see me
ice-skating but I at least tried it so
you can try new traditions as well so it
could be Christmas movies so Ryan
mentioned the cheesy Christmas music but
when I think of this time of year in
traditions quite often I think of all
the the nostalgic Christmas movies that
I saw from the pathos or you could watch
new Christmas movies as well you know in
fact one of the traditions I had for a
very long time and may even bring it
back was I would go to the movies on
Christmas Day after all of the shuffling
around so when I was married we'd go
from it was not the most optimal
experience we'd like go from from my
house we'd have Christmas I don't it was
a brunch I don't know what it was
Christmas brunch and then we'd have
Christmas lunch and then we'd have
Christmas post-lunch celebration at
Carey's family and you know we'd go to 3
or 4 places on Christmas Day but
afterward once all the chaos was over
we'd go see a movie and I always make
sure I think the people were working
that day and say hey thank you for being
here I know that it's not the most
optimal time for you to be working and
just appreciate the fact that you are
here so start new traditions I don't
know if there you have any other
traditions that come to mind Ryan Oh
next weekend Becca is taking Ella skiing
with her whole families I won't be there
skiing because I've tried the whole
snowboarding thing and and my body just
doesn't agree with the laws of physics
felt so bad when I took you snowboard
remember we just ended up getting tubes
and like sledding down the hill that's
fun so that's a good tradition anyone
could do so especially like kids that
may not have the aptitude for skiing or
six-foot-two adults they don't have the
aptitude for skiing that that certainly
helps so find a tradition that is ideal
for you and replace some of these old
ones because like I said a a tradition
is is not flexible but it can't they are
replaceable with new better more
empowering traditions that you can carry
forward into the future yeah and you
know I think one thing too
is it's okay to support traditions that
you're not a hundred percent on board
with lake for example I'm going back to
the cookies uh-huh
let's say that you know I go to family
members house and just like Sara's
they've always got you know fourteen
different kinds of cookies out it I
don't have to eat those cookies right
and even if you know like some are
forced upon me to bring home right
I could always like give those cookies
to someone else you would really really
enjoy those but going through the whole
process and experience you know going to
your mom or dad and saying wow this is
really nice spread of cookies yeah you
always do a really these cookies are so
beautiful right and you know the cookies
that you give me I'm always able to
share those with others and they really
appreciate them so and I'm just using
that you know the cookies as an example
here but finding ways to support other
people in their traditions that make
them happy mm-hmm I mean that's also a
good way to kind of help create closer
bonds but you can still abstain if that
makes sense
it does yeah and I would say there are
some traditions that are more pernicious
than others and we're recording this the
last day of November it's gonna it's not
going to post for about two weeks
but recording this the the last day of
of November and so Black Friday was not
that long ago right it was it was what
five days ago and then there was what
Cyber Monday but there was a really good
yesterday the day before recording this
there was giving Tuesday right which is
which is a new thing now it's weird that
we seems unbelievably like crazy though
like bye bye bye bye bye okay now it's
time to get yeah yeah so but about you
giving me a break I'm just you know what
III think that the tradition of of
getting up early to go shopping is a
tradition that we can replace with
something else so maybe you get up early
to do to do something different you know
the whole opt out side thing has been a
big thing now it is it is promoted by
many retailers so it's questionable as
to whether and what the motives are
there but I will I can tell you place
like REI that closed on Black Friday
that is I applaud that right because
awesome they can do
they could do a lot of business on that
day and instead they they choose not to
and and Patagonia did you see what they
did no I've seen several things that
they've done in the past what they do
recently uh so they did do Black Friday
okay had sales they made over it was
over ten million I think on Black Friday
donated one hundred percent of it to
charity oh wow that's great and yeah
they're doing some other really cool
stuff now with their the recycling down
from old Jackie yeah so they're just
they're very intentional retailer you
know which those two words sound like an
oxymoron at first but there are good
local businesses but there are also some
some large corporations a lot of be
corpse as well do we need jackets in
Montana indeed indeed we do and so yes
you you can you can say no to these
other traditions that are you perceived
to be precious or harmful to you but
then the other ones that are innocuous
you can replace with something that you
find more meaningful you know I just I
just had this thought so you know how we
always say like with your time and
resources you say no to a lot of things
so you can say yes to others yes like in
this situation I think it's the opposite
I think you say yes to as many
traditions as you can so then you can go
to your family members and say hey I
participate as much as I can and that
kind of gives you leverage to say no
yeah to other traditions well it's funny
Becca's dealing with this right now with
with Ella her family they do like a
sibling gift exchange so they're not all
forced because she has she's one of four
siblings and then her two parents and so
they're not all forced to buy gifts with
each other the six of them just have a
sort of exchange where is it the white
elephant kind of thing where you get
someone's name and you give them a gift
well vex opted out altogether she's like
yeah I don't need anything you know I've
I don't need any physical gifts thank
you but she opted Ella into the gift
exchange okay which is really cool until
the entire family pushes back and says
well we all want to buy a gift for Ella
and so what we're dealing with right now
is I said you know that's fine but let's
encourage the right kind of gift-giving
and let's let's let's put the burden
back on the gift giver the person who
wants to give the gift because we want
we want them to feel good about the act
of giving but let's encourage them let's
steer them in a direction of giving an
experience as opposed to a physical gift
and so it's all about framing instead of
saying no I don't want you to buy a gift
for Ella I mean that that's just bad for
everyone why not say yes
we can start the tradition of gifting
experiences for Ella because she has all
the toys that she needs right now yeah
it's funny because like people think
like kids always need more toys and kids
open a present they get excited when
they see a toy but really kids get
excited when they open anything
absolutely it doesn't have to be a toy I
Ella just started chewing gum recently
and she's just getting used to it like
she's trying to figure out the whole
chewing gum I'd say she gets more
excited about unwrapping that pack of
gum than just about anything else I saw
this YouTube video of this kid for his
birthday as a joke their family put a
banana in a gift bag and put like tissue
paper on top of it yeah and they were
like okay this is from all of us and
they hand it in the bag
and he pulls out the tissue paper and he
pulled the banana out and I have never
seen a kid so excited about banana as a
gift I haven't seen that one but I did
it well on her birthday it was a book
that's great not a banana it was a
pineapple it's yeah it's supposed to be
like this you know it was supposed to be
this joke uh-huh like oh we're gonna
make the kid upset but then we're gonna
actually give them the real gift but it
end up being like this really amazing
lesson like wow a kid's no matter what
they're unwrapping they're just happy to
have the attention they're happy to have
the love they're happy to have the
family around and it doesn't have to be
some amazing you know toy that lights up
some kind of Voltron thing that I would
have wanted for Christmas when I was
again like it doesn't have to be that
though necessarily to be a meaningful
experience it was supposed to be a joke
with a joke and end up being on them and
there
right yeah and and so I think it's
important I'll do that with Ella all
kinds of stuff like whether it's so I
should can't read yet but I'll get her
cards sometimes and then they shall have
backs read the card to her like a
million times because it's strangely
more meaningful to her than any you know
no Peppa Pig doll that I could get her
or whatever the the latest kids toys so
is she excited about the pineapple yeah
totally
that's all she's more excited about
about the balloons that I got her but
she just balloons but yeah she was
totally excited about the pineapple yeah
you could tell was a pineapple was
wrapped up all goofy and like it was in
the shape of a pineapple that's great
but you're right there she loved what
she was really excited about was the act
of unwrapping yeah and she so yeah she's
excited about unwrapping a pineapple or
a piece of gum or a toy or expirience
let's let's create those experiences for
the kids as opposed to just fulfilling a
a cultural expectation alright we'd love
to hear what you have to say of course
so if you have a comment about the
holidays including minimalism tips for
how you handle the holidays leave us a
voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 will air
our favorite comments and tips on the
next episode and here is a tip for you
write down your message before you call
in that will help you articulate your
point and it will increase your chance
of being on the show ok you know what
time it is Millie what time is it it's
time for hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we are on
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
and facebook.com slash the minimalists
and during this lightning round Ryan and
I do our best to answer each question
which is a short shareable less than 140
character response we'll also put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in our
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like alright our first question is from
Levi he asks during holiday events how
do you maximize your contributions to
family festivities
being mindful well here's what I would
say I'd say the best way to contribute
is to accept support and appreciate your
loved ones yeah amen that's totally
agree with that if you are if you're
trying to contribute you have to first
understand the person in order to
understand them you have to do exactly
what you're talking about they're right
for me just three bees for you be
present be attentive just be so if
you're gonna be there for the holidays
be there right and so I think that's an
important thing to remember we're not
off browsing our Twitter streams or
whatever it may be just be there yeah
leave your phone in the car during the
holidays I hang out with your family not
with your phone amen yeah ma'am Cassie
she writes in would you please talk
about how everyone rushes around all
stressed out complaining about how busy
they are during the holiday season I
hate that you know busyness doesn't
always equal productivity and it
certainly doesn't always meet adding
value totally agree my tweetable
response would be busyness has become a
status symbol but it is a vacuous
endeavor busy is the phallus four-letter
word in the English language and so yeah
right this is a time of year where a lot
of people do feel busy I remember back
when we I mean this was the worst time
of year for me mm-hmm
a decade ago right these are the 80-hour
weeks kicked in for sure absolutely
even more often hundred hour weeks on
Black Friday I'd worked 16 to 18 hours
in one day and and so we were in the
throes of the holiday shopping season
and it was a very stressful time for us
but I know it's stressful for other
people for different reasons if they're
not working in retail it could be
because finances are are tight and we
have these expectations and the average
person spends nearly $700 a year on
Christmas and we can't afford to all of
us to do that and so what are we doing
we're racking up debt and trying to pay
it off throughout the year
and the cycle keeps us busy and makes us
have to work more it focuses our
attention in places where we don't want
to focus and so we need to be careful
about busy and find a way to be more
focused on on the holidays that are
right here in front of us Karla writes
can you talk about those of us who don't
have many friends and family loneliness
and isolation is real for a lot of
people especially during the holidays
you know this question like really just
made me feel for Karla because yeah it's
it's as an extrovert imagining being in
kind of a vacuum where I didn't have a
support group or community people around
me like that would really yeah it would
just be have negative effect on me but
you know I would say are you feeling
lonely this holiday season the best way
to create a bond with your community is
to contribute soup kitchens would love
your help so just going out and adding
value to the community that is one way
to connect yeah absolutely yeah I agree
with that I mean a few years ago while
we were on we were on our holiday
happiness tour man I guess it was four
years ago now and we so we weren't home
for the holidays we're in Vancouver
Canada and what we were doing was we got
a group of readers together and brought
them all to a not a soup kitchen but but
a Food Bank and helped work a Food Bank
for Christmas Day and it was it was a
good opportunity to connect with all
those people but also just to connect
with a community that needed some help
and so you can certainly do that Ryan
and I have worked at a lot of soup
kitchens or Habitat for Humanity and
places like that and they would love
your help but not just during the
holidays throughout the year is a great
way to connect with others so if you're
missing that connection during the
holidays do it now if you need a
connection other times do it then my
pithy response for Karla is lonely and
alone are not synonyms sometimes a
crowded place can feel the most alone so
remember that as well so just because
you're around other people doesn't mean
that you're connecting to them as well a
connection takes more than just
proximity Emily asks how do you decorate
your home to look festive without a
bunch of stuff you know a bunch of stuff
or not I think that's the wrong question
the meaningful question is what adds the
most value to your life Emily yeah I
agree
we just said I simply decorated home is
the most elegant home and to expand on
that I'll just say that you know we got
a house tour coming up on our site soon
Ryan's just posted recently you can take
a look at our home and it's it's fairly
sparsely decorated but that makes any of
the decorations whether it's a piece of
artwork or the Christmas tree or the
lights or the ornaments or whatever it
makes it that seem far more intentional
and and enjoyable because of that and so
while we may not have decorations strewn
everywhere we do have some Christmas
lights we do have a Christmas tree we do
have stocking you know we have things
that were decided on intentionally but
because it's so simple to me at least it
feels like it's the most elegant choice
yeah I mean I know people who like I had
an ex-girlfriend whose mom would put out
like hundreds of Santa Clauses right
like as many Santa Clauses as she could
put out for decorations uh-huh it was
gorgeous
uh-huh like she did in a very
intentional way they were throughout the
whole house and it was I thought it was
really really gorgeous
I think the key there is intention then
yeah again just like go buy a bunch of
Santa's and drop them on her lawn or
something right it wasn't there was no
there was no tackiness at all with the
decorations because it was intention as
it was intentional yeah so you know it
being a minimalist doesn't mean not
having Christmas decorations
it doesn't mean not having you know
paintings on your walls it's funny but
one of my house tour like one of the
biggest criticisms was oh this is
unbelievable
his stark white walls I can never live
there and it's like well you don't live
there I do
it's funny of vexed mom was in town and
she came over the house and I think you
know this is just too sparsely decorated
for me and she's like that's okay like I
don't trying to get you to live this way
you don't have to have sports well if
you want to put yeah a bunch of pictures
on your walls or a bunch of Christmas
decorations great I would just I would
just say if you want it to be beautiful
then make sure it's deliberate and
you're not just you know screwing stuff
across your place for the sake of it you
know someone asked where's all your
artwork I said it's at the museum down
the street I get to enjoy it whenever I
want it's really awesome and they often
change it out and I don't have to do any
work but that said just because I love
particular Wyatt doesn't mean I'm
prescribing it to anyone else I think
that's where where people get your
caught up we have a very good minimalist
friend Jessica Jess Ness who actually
helps us with a lot of our social media
our Facebook stuff if you see a lot of
the articles that we post she goes out
and finds articles about simple living
and and simplicity and intentionality
her and her friend Melissa also run a
great podcast called the mind Palace and
she's an artist and so you go to their
home and there's artwork all over their
walls it's it's sparse otherwise in
terms of decorations but she has a ton
of art all over her house and that's
just because that's what she finds the
most value in and that's great so can
you be a minimalist and have a ton of
artwork and Santa Claus figurines yeah
if it adds value to your life and so ask
yourself that question
Jennifer writes in how do you manage
holiday schedules with all the potlucks
parties and get-togethers
Jennifer party invitations are just that
an invite you get to decide what you do
with your time yeah I totally agree with
that man I think what we get caught up
in is letting everyone dictate our
schedules right and so my my short
answer is say no to almost everything so
you can say yes to that which is most
important and so if you're asked to go
to a million functions million
networking events and holiday parties
and everything else
know everything that you can say no to
so the ones you say yes to you'll get
the most value from and you'll also be
able to add the most value to those
functions because you'll be present you
will actually be there and everyone will
enjoy your presence because of that
Becky asks I don't want my kids to
believe in Santa Claus how do you keep
them magic and fun in the holidays
without that tradition you know I uh I I
don't like I don't I'm not a you know
practicing Jehovah's Witness anymore
uh-huh
but I still don't want to like lie to my
kids about Santa Claus right so this is
kind of like a tricky a tricky subject
but I'm really glad to hear like other
people out there besides a religious
group is like you know intentionally
saying okay I don't want to lie to my
kids you know what else you know what
else what else can I do to to combat
that what I would say is it kind of Josh
touched on it earlier there's always
room for new traditions what matters
most is that your family knows you love
and support them I agree if I were to
add to that I would just quickly say
honesty is the bedrock of the most
healthy traditions true so so you think
about Santa Claus I don't want we
believe in Santa Claus either and Beck
and I were just talking about this
recently because it's that time where
other kids around her are being told
that there's a Santa Claus and I also
don't want her to be the I don't want it
to be you and you were five going around
telling everyone there isn't a Santa
Claus there's a balance right yeah and
and tried to upset all the kids just
because and I understand why because
you're different you don't want to feel
left out right you want to be
significant but you also want to have
this connection with other people and
you don't if everyone else believes in
Santa Claus except your kid you're gonna
feel disconnected and that's not a good
thing
and so the balance that I found is yes
we can talk about Santa Claus Santa
Claus is a for me it is a a fictitious
character right like I I can look at
Santa Claus say well that is a story
that's made up and it's a fable and I
can communicate it the same way to a law
that I would communicate Peppa Pig she
doesn't think probably
have any idea what peplum is no idea
this is a British family of pigs that
Ella is obsessed with and we we instead
of on Sunday mornings we let her watch
Peppa Pig and and so she believes that
Peppa Pig is a story it's an animated
fiction and I think I'm okay with her
believing that Santa Claus is also an
animated fiction it's just a story and
that's really the way that we approach
it and it's it's the most honest way for
me to approach it it's not depriving her
of that story but it's also not lying to
her and saying that some fat man breaks
into our house on Christmas Eve and
reverse shoplifts under our Christmas
tree okay
well now it's time for our added-value
portion of the show this is where we
each recommend something that has added
value to our lives recently Ryan it's
I'm gonna call an audible here because
you mentioned Christmas songs I have a
Christmas playlist on my iTunes or Apple
music whatever you call it and one of
our favorite musicians finally wrote a
Christmas song his name's Andrew Bell he
had two new singles come out this year
once called dive deep and one was called
you but then he has this new Christmas
song so we'll put a link to that
Christmas song in the show notes it's
it's actually really good song I didn't
even know it was a Christmas song at
first and so I started listening to the
lyrics have you read The Killers
Christmas album they put out no dude
it's it's great it really the first song
on it is called uh
I don't know if it's called this but
like the choruses please don't shoot me
Santa like you know they it's like a
Christmas album from The Killers like
and they put their twist on it it's it's
it's pretty it's pretty good yeah gotta
like the killers and to like it I mean
it ain't no William Shatner Christmas if
you're gonna go to see a movie on
Christmas Day or any time during the
holidays a movie I saw recently I really
enjoyed was moonlight we was over at the
Roxy at the indie theater here it's
gotten really good reviews and
rightfully so it was just a gorgeously
done three-act movie follows his
character's life a black man who grows
up poor in Miami Florida
and struggles with being a gay kid in a
culture that just didn't accept him and
so I found that the movie really
compelling and by the end of it you know
you kind of feel you feel for his
struggle was it has very little to do
with him being a gay man and as just
more to do with the struggles of
humanity and that happened to be his
particular struggle I got two
recommendations this this episode last
night I had like a lose a small game
night there was only there were only a
few of us over there were only 17 people
at his house right now there's it was
just a few of us and we were playing
this game called civilization and it is
if you know how to play the game takes
like four or five hours to play we
didn't know how to play so we were like
four hours first time you played it yeah
first time I played it we were four
hours into it and we still we weren't
even halfway through what's the object
of the game the object they take over
the world
no the object of the game I don't play
them the object of the game is to build
a civilization and there are some break
over the world there are several ways to
win whether you dominate certain
resources haha no I mean I would the
only the only thing that this has in
common with like a world take over a
game like risk uh-huh is that it's a big
map with a lot of pieces uh-huh but it
has way more rules and it's not all it's
not about just battling other
civilizations is about making your own
collecting resources but that's what's
kind of cool about it it's like cuz the
one thing that I hate what happens
during certain games like monopoly is
like I remember when we were kids I
don't really play Monopoly anymore but I
remember when we were kids like 20% of
the time like the board would end up
like getting flipped over because you
get so angry at one another for
everything but with civilization it's
like you are working against each other
but it's not in like a direct attacking
way so it's like for Passover yeah it's
more passive-aggressive but it's it's
it's a lot of fun I don't really know
how to I was trying to think like how
the heck am I gonna explain this game
and I really don't know how but you know
I'm not necessarily recommending
civilization
what I am recommending is that you could
potentially buy a boardgame something
like civilization mm-hmm gift that to
someone and create an experience during
the holiday season with with family and
friends and it's you know an experience
that you can recreate for as long as you
have that game so anyone out there who's
looking for you know like a good
Christmas idea who they want to get a
physical item they want to give it to
someone I think that's a very meaningful
gift man is like getting someone a nice
game like our cards against humanity' no
dude that was fun so we tried to get
that last year for Christmastime and
that idea got poo-pooed up the
off-the-chain when i when i ran it up
the chain i guess they weren't ready for
cards against humanity' funny thing is
we've played that with some of our
audience before we get out on tour and
all of a sudden will be at say a coffee
shop across the street from the venue
and then someone recognizes us and then
we'll just break out the cards against
humanity' and you get to learn the
darkest side of other people really
quickly in that game so it's a fun way
to learn the depths of someone's
personality well and it gives you an
excuse to like be totally inappropriate
yes and without any consequences exactly
yes cards yeah it's it's like yeah it
gives you a freedom the other
recommendation dude I don't think I told
you this um so a couple days ago Mariah
and I went and butchered a lamb actually
Mariah didn't go it was me and Mariah
had to stay back and watch her
grandmother so I went and butchered a
lamb but her her mom and I went to a
friend's house and she was selling whole
lambs and we basically like chopped it
up now I heard it in this in like the
pejorative sense it was not like nice
cuts it was it was it was kind of hacked
up but what I'll say about that
experience is like we've had a couple
meals out of it dude I appreciate the
like the meat so much more like putting
the work into it wow I didn't know I
wasn't actually there for like the
slaughter it's not like
like when we showed up it was skinned
and like all the guts were out of it and
stuff
but it really you know not just helped
me appreciate the the animal more and
were that that food was coming from but
it was a really just educational
experience on okay like especially
living in Montana
in the middle of nowhere it's like
alright if I was to you know hunt an
animal or something like you know this
is you know kind of an idea of how I
would you know cut it up or whatever
yeah but I just I think there's a huge
disconnect total with our food I have
like literally you know I've seen
instances where someone has a steak in
front of them and they're eating the
steak and you know someone mentions like
how Oh like I if you like that steak
you'd love that you love the the steak
from the cows that I raised you know I
make sure that they're grass-fed and
then like someone who's eating the steak
will look at them and say you kill those
poor animals oh good I mean they're just
like this huge disconnect that you
describe your true it is true because
we've made getting food so easy in our
society yeah because you go to your the
freezer section of your local grocery
store and pick out a slab of meat right
and you have you know you have no idea
and I feel like in order to from me like
in order for me to you know eat me
because I just started eating meat was
lat it was last year beginning of the
year I make sure that I am being as
responsible as I can with that food
mm-hmm and you know a couple days ago I
took it a step further aware like I went
out and you know pretty much like made
my you know participated in making the
food I guess to another level but uh but
yeah I would just my recommendation is
not to go butcher a lamb but get more
connected with your food and maybe that
doesn't mean going out and like my mom
she took my brother's mm-hmm out to a
pork you know pork pork packaging plant
and she basically was like hey
to my little brothers like hey um this
is what you eat you have to know where
it comes from
that's great man and you know I'm not
saying like put your kids to it you know
to a plant like that I don't know if
that was good or bad or what but no I
think it is because it's funny because I
started eating red meat this the summer
I guess again and it's food is medicine
like still over 90% of my diet is
plant-based but I've had to increase my
red meat - because I'm anemic and so on
Thanksgiving we had elk steak oh well I
kept calling it a low steak and she was
getting so mad at me anyway and we were
eating it and she L was very connected
with with nature especially cuz her dad
is a Fisher and spends all of his time
outdoors and what when
Beck's was telling Ella that we're gonna
eat hello she goes mom you can't eat
Alcon til you shoot it first like she
gets she understands the whole process
and she she understands you know what it
takes you to to get an animal on your
plate you first have to you know kill it
and I think you're right it helps you
appreciate the the overall experience
now do you want to take a couple of
five-year-old kids who don't have any
idea where meat is it comes from and set
them in in a a factory farm butchering
plant no I mean that that's that's
terrible
and in traumatizing but if you can
condition someone from an early age to
understand as opposed to to conditioning
them to think that food is just
ultimately readily available like you
and I thought growing up then because
even though we grew up or like food was
just it was still available right it
wasn't crap food and but but it was
still there man so yeah that's that that
is it was it was a heck of an experience
man it was can't even explain it but it
totally I guess just helped me I can't
explain why I really can't put my finger
on it but it really helped me just
appreciate
even more like we were eating some lamb
stew last night mm-hm and it's like wow
like there's a lot of work that goes
into this meat especially like it being
raised you know grass-fed finished with
hay
it just it makes the meal that much more
enjoyable and yeah it just keeps me you
know grounded I guess there's gratitude
there for sure yeah yeah all right well
let's move on to right here right now
this is where we get to talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists great news we heard you loud
and clear our documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is finally available on Netflix this
week that this episode is airing so this
will be airing on the 13th in two days
on December 15th December 15th
minimalism a documentary about the
important things will finally be
available on Netflix does this mean we
made it we made it onto Netflix yes if
you don't have Netflix that's okay
because obviously it's still available
on iTunes and Google Play and Amazon and
worldwide on Vimeo I know in some
countries for whatever reason certain
laws it's not available on iTunes or
Netflix in every country but it's
available worldwide on on Vimeo it's
also available in North America on DVD
if you're still old-school and still
have that DVD player hooked up then
we've got you covered we just hope that
you you minimize the film afterward on
to someone else who can get value from
it it makes a great stocking stuffer but
only if it's a used DVD also we're going
on tour a little bit next year we're
doing a few small tour stops next year
we don't have any announcements yet in
terms of cities that's coming very soon
but you can subscribe to our email
newsletter at the minimalists dot-com to
be the first to hear about the upcoming
events we're gonna do three or four at a
time we're gonna bring a simple idea to
your city and together we're going to
deconstruct that idea we're going to
talk about that idea and we're gonna
listen to you and everything you have to
say about that idea so it's some new
material that we're gonna
or we're going to be building throughout
2017 so make sure you're on our email
newsletter just go to the minimalists
comm and type in your email there at the
top where it says email a newsletter
that's about it Ryan I'm doing some
traveling this month we were talking
about that before before the the podcast
started rolling
I'm headed to Dayton soon Los Angeles
for a long weekend that's gonna be fun
like Bex and I just have like a four-day
weekend without Ella so we're going to
be in Los Angeles no public events going
on but I'll be back in st. Pete for
Christmastime we're doing some
coffeehouse upgrades our coffee shop
there bandit Coffee Co we're doing some
upgrades to the shop to the retail space
and I've been playing around with the
minimalist city finds on Instagram
posting pictures of like whenever I go
to a new city and museums just Indy
businesses cryotherapy float tanks
whatever it may be just just creating
these new experiences in different
cities trying to really catalog a way
for people if they go to a city like st.
Petersburg or Dayton Ohio or Los Angeles
to have a reference of well here are
some places the minimalist like so you
can find that over on our Instagram page
at the minimalists hope you find some
some value in that alright finally here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners hi my name is Jessica
I'm calling from Las Vegas Nevada I was
just calling to make a comment or a
suggestion I asked about going minimal
with children I was listening to a
previous podcast of yours and somebody
said that their daughter stuff was
driving them crazy
and I just think that a lot of the stuff
that our children accrue is their gifts
from birthdays and holidays etc from
grandparents and other family members so
what I decided to do with my son is he
wants to go Disneyland for his birthday
so what we're doing is we're asking
people instead of buying him gifts to
get him gift cards to Disney
first birthday so that will kind of help
fund that experience for him so they're
drifting him and experience instead of
gifting him in physical toys or physical
things um and does any Disney it could
be anything like turns museums or like a
live show cartoon he watches is doing a
live show here so that's another option
there's lots of indoor activities for
kids here in Las Vegas so they could
definitely get gift cards to any type of
things like that or sporting event as
ooh anything like that and then you
could just send them a picture of your
child at the event or whatever and that
will you know make them feel good about
getting them an experience versus
getting them a physical toy because it
can be awkward for grandparents to make
that transition and a friend of mine was
actually saying that she has her child
donate a toy every time she gets a new
one so that's kind of another option you
have to do what works best for your own
child in your own family my name is
Lindsay I'm from Pottsville Pennsylvania
and I'm calling about your episode on
gift-giving because I had a response to
it I love your ideas about giving
experiences taking people to events and
things like that and I have a little bit
more to add to that I am a single person
who lives at home and I have no children
but I have a lot of friends who are
married and have kids and sometimes
giving them tickets or gift certificates
or things like that to events and
experiences can become a little bit
burdensome because you know like one of
my friends has to get me a babysitter
and that runs really expensively
so one of the things that I am doing for
her and her husband for this Christmas
is I am buying them tickets to go see a
show but then also including with it a
little coupon for one free night as
babies today I know both of their sons
and they're super cool and he's fun to
hang out with and they trust me so it
would be able to get them out of the
house and also they can have faith in me
that things are going to go well at home
as well hi my name is Susan I'm a
working mom in Havertown Pennsylvania
and I have twin three-year-old boys and
I have a great tip that's worked out in
terms of sharing minimalist ideologies
with my children I'm sure that I know
one of you has a little kid in your life
and they grow so quickly out of toys and
there's just as a commune relation of
junk and instead of telling them oh
where there's kids that you know really
need these toys which I don't think it's
great to talk about guilt and privilege
with toddlers will say oh you've really
grown out of these toys what if we
donate them when we can make more space
and I'll tell you what we'll get one you
know big boy toy that really suits your
needs right now and they love that and
both of them filled up a garbage bag
recently and we donated it to the
goodwill and I plan on doing it maybe
every six months I don't even say look
at all this extra space we have to play
with blue or that's our dog or play
monsters or hide-and-seek and they're
all about it so it's just really worked
for me to not do the guilt of you know
lots of kids need these toys or you're
so lucky and you should really share so
I just wanted to share that with the
other parents out there the people of
little kids in their lives alright y'all
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
[Music]